good morning Hank it's Sunday it's
Newsday and today the news is no more
wall actually that's not the real news
today we're gonna talk about sex
specifically the sex of distance runner
caster Semenya so Hank caster Semenya is
an eighteen-year-old South African
runner who bursts out of nowhere to win
the 800 meter race at the World
Championships in Berlin and then some of
our competitors said that Semenya had a
distinct advantage in the women's 800
meter race the advantage of not being a
woman so this poor eighteen-year-old had
to undergo a gender test and it's now
being widely reported that Semenya may
have an intersex condition specifically
and drogyn an insensitivity syndrome
androgen insensitivity syndrome is this
thing where chromosomal e you may be a
woman but you have small undescended
testes now I'm before we go any further
I want to say that a lot of teenagers
sometimes feel uncomfortable about their
bodies and they could be quite
vulnerable to teasing I just want
everyone to take a moment to imagine how
it would feel to have millions of people
around the world discussing your
internal testes Hank even though caster
Semenya is only 18 she's responded to
all of this heroically by saying she's
proud to be the person God made her and
she's proud of her achievements and that
she is a woman now a lot of people say
that the complaints of caster Semenya
competitors are just sour grapes Hank
remember that time that I said sour
grapes and talked about internal testes
in the same video I love my job but I
would argue that the problem is not with
semenya or her competitors but with
sports itself so Hank we like to think
of sex as an either/or proposition
you're either male or female
even though about 1% of human beings are
born neither male nor female but with
some kind of intersex condition Hank my
friend Lauren McLaughlin wrote about all
of this in a really interesting blog
post linked in the sidebar and she
argued that sports is basically an
attempt to remove ambiguity from the
human condition like one of the problems
with the human condition is that no
victory is ever final or assured right
that's why you don't put a mission
accomplished banner on your aircraft
carrier being a person means never
really knowing if you can celebrate like
a wedding is wonderful unless it leads
to divorce winning the lottery is
awesome unless it allows you to develop
the cocaine habit you've always wanted
in life all the things that we wish
could be clear and unambiguous like
victory and love and sex never end up
being clear sports allows us to have
that
of ambiguity so often when people win
trophies and sports they hold it up and
say they can't take this away from us
they say that because in the non sports
world fraught with ambiguity everything
else can be taken away
you always hear sports guys say like
sports is like life but what we love
about sports is that it's not like life
there's no room for ambiguity in sports
that's why we have photo finishes an
instant replay and that's also why
sports will always be well fun kind of
insufficient Hank it seems to me that
the people who failed here are the
administrators of the sport who should
have decided in advance whether Semenya
would be eligible to compete and as
always in sports we're gonna have to
live with some dumb arbitrary but
unambiguous rules it's been widely
reported that some men use testosterone
levels fall within the range of normal
for a woman in which case she should be
allowed to compete with women but
regardless Hank I for one will remember
caster Semenya spur formance on and off
the track as unambiguously heroic Hank
you'll see me tomorrow
cue the outro